after the treasury Chris felt with us
now goodness me good morning to you how
embarrassing is this
good morning Kay well I think as the
chancellor said this morning uh this is
a government that listens quite clearly
the proposal to remove that additional
rate the 45p band was proving uh to be a
distraction from The Wider package of
growth measures which help everybody
they were very broadly based tax cuts
and so listening to what the public have
said and also what members of parliament
conservative members of parliament have
said the chancellor and prime minister
have decided not to proceed with that
measure but they are of course
proceeding with all the rest of the
growth plan the other 95 of it which
includes very broadly based tax cuts
that will benefit everybody the average
family will be about 430 pounds a year
better off and we're going to get
Britain's economy growing which
ultimately will generate more tax
revenues to pay for public services see
wages rising and see the jobs of the
future getting created so we're going to
focus on that 95 of the package which I
think commands widespread support and
not proceed with this relatively small
measure which clearly did not come on
support
you're his right hand man how involved
were you in the decision to cut that top
rate of tax
well these decisions are made ultimately
by the Prime Minister and the chancellor
they obviously talk to a lot of
colleagues um you know across the
cabinet and indeed Beyond I mean the
Prime Minister and Chancellor have been
talking uh to members of parliament in
the last few days on on this question
and on others so they draw there they
talk to a lot of different people
um ultimately they obviously make the
decisions
you're his right hand man how involved
we were you in the process
I will obviously they talk to me about
these things but as I say they talk to a
lot of people about this because how
involved were you in the process
well you know the Prime Minister and
Chancellor talked to me about this as
they talk to other people
um but it's not a you know it's a
government which is broadly based they
were talking to a lot of MPS across the
Parliamentary party in the last few days
who are obviously speaking for their
constituents
um and ultimately the Prime Minister and
Chancellor decided to change tack
because they obviously aren't listening
this is a government that listens and
that's what they've done but the key
point is that 95 of this growth plan by
value you said that is going ahead
absolutely and it will help get our
economy growing okay sure Mr Phil
um did you present the chancellor and
the would-be prime minister with a paper
outlining that this would be a good idea
during the election campaign for the new
prime minister
and I was asked to look at whole like
dozens and dozens did you or did you not
present them
this was a good idea
I'm not gonna go I'm not going to go
into the details of what ideas were or
were not discussed by cabinets because
those are those are because those are
private conversations okay and what I'm
interested in talking about is the
growth countries wages Rising was it
your idea
I would not describe it as my idea no
um but we discussed lots of ideas I
discussed those ideas that I was asked
to analyze different ideas and we
discussed dozens of dozens dozens of
different things they were discussed
with me with lots and lots of other
people members of parliament and other
people as well we put together the
growth plan which will get our economy
growing it will see wages rising and it
will see a sustainable attack Mr felt
did you for public services well it's an
important did you present mistras and Mr
uh quateng with a paper suggesting that
this is what would happen if there was a
cut from 40. I did not I did not 40p
okay okay I did not produce a paper
specifically on this measure we
discussed within a different ideas
okay I think I've said as much as I want
to say about this lots and lots of
different ideas
thank you on it and my question is as
part of the paper as part of a work as a
part of a body of work that was given to
them during the election campaign did
you suggest in writing that this could
be a good idea
I'm not gonna go any further into
discussion private discussions that were
held over the summer I'm not I've said
as much as I want to say about this you
know there were widespread discussions
involving me involving other people
involving dozens of different ideas
and you know decisions ultimately
um get made by the chancellor and by the
Prime Minister listening to a lot of
different people
your idea wasn't it
I wouldn't describe it as my idea no
whose idea was it
I've already said a lot of different
ideas got discussed by a lot of
different people during the course of
the campaign and subsequently um but the
growth plan the whole growth plan was a
team effort which was debated and
ultimately decided on by the Prime
Minister and the chancellor and the
growth plan is an extremely positive
plan it will see taxes falling for every
single working family by an average of
430 pounds each it'll see infrastructure
projects getting expedited it will see
they saw the energy Intervention which
is stopping families who would otherwise
have faced bills of six seven thousand
Pounds a year getting those bills capped
at two and a half thousand pounds a year
on average instead it'll see domestic
energy supplies getting stimulated so it
no longer reliant on importing
electricity from overseas so this is a
really positive plan and talking to
members of parliament or listening to
what they've been saying and I think
almost all of this plan is being widely
welcomed there was this one element
that's now being removed to avoid it
being a distraction
do you think that people should own
their mistakes
look I think this government is one that
like any government is one that should
listen
to our democracy
um we should listen to the public we're
a parliamentary democracy so we should
listen to MPS and I think when a measure
is found which uh doesn't which is
proving to be a distraction which
doesn't command
um the support that we would like to see
then it's a sensible and responsive
thing so rather than being very sort of
inflexible and saying we're not going to
listen we're just going to plow on
anyway to be responsive and to change
course is the right thing to do
um that is you know I think you'd like
to see your viewers would like to see a
government which listens and which
responds to parliamentary opinions
obviously MP speak for their
constituents and for constituents
directly as well and I see that as a a
point of sort of maturity and strength
frankly and Berlin what the chancellor
is going to be talking about today in
his speech just after four o'clock are
the positive elements in the growth plan
that will get our country grown which I
know I have said once or twice before
okay fantastic we know what time the
speech is uh let's come back to the
point do you think I'm sure my viewers
will want to know do do you think that
politicians should own their mistakes
well I think you know the chance has
been going on TV on other TV programs
this morning
um well as I say of course politicians
should be responsible and but you're not
getting what you're saying today you're
not owning your mistake are you well
I mean that's I don't think that's um of
accurate or fair to be quite honest
why
well because you know these are broadly
based discussions lots of people are
involved the decisions are taken by the
Prime Minister and the chancellor
um I was one of many people involved in
those discussions and I don't accept
your characterization
okay so you didn't put anything in
writing at all that said that this was a
good idea
because obviously if there's a bit of
pain that's going to come
across stage now's your opportunity to
say whether you did or not I just told
you I just told you I analyzed a whole
different idea a number of ideas
um
I'm giving you the opportunity to own
your mistake
and I'm saying I'm not going to get into
the details of who said what when when
policies get discussed and made
internally but people don't give a
running commentary on exactly who was
involved in which discussion a lot of
different people were involved a lot of
different ideas got discussed by
different people
um and I think that people will
understand that what matters now is that
we've listened uh to public opinion
we've listened to parliamentary opinion
this idea clearly wasn't popular and
therefore we've removed it so it's not a
distraction from the very positive wider
growth plan when did you realize it was
a bad idea
well I think the economics of it there's
a very strong case for doing it as I've
been saying uh probably on your program
I don't think you were presenting that
day but um you know there's three
reasons of international competitiveness
there is a strong economic case but it's
become very clear over the last few days
um that the public uh and parliamentary
opinion uh don't don't like the idea um
for a variety of reasons and so we've
responded to that because we are a
government that listens and that's I
think a good thing
yeah but I mean you were cutting 50 so a
millionaire would get an extra 55 000
pounds a year but you weren't restoring
the uh Universal Credit uplift that
would mean that 55 000 pounds a year
that Universal Credit would would pay
for 57 years for a family of four we're
in the middle of a cost of living crisis
people cannot Heat their homes and you
and others thought it was a good idea to
cut the tax that millionaires were
paying at what stage
were you listening reading the runes
listening to what the public was saying
well first of all no decisions have been
made on Universal Credit the DWP
secretary will go through uh the normal
process in the course of the Autumn uh
secondly it's possible that that could
come back sorry just to pick you up on
that is that going to come back
what is what gonna come back Universal
Credit uplift that that's not been
completely off the table because I've
been speaking to your colleagues last
week and they said it hasn't been
decided I mean it hasn't been or that
you're the Chancellor's right hand man
you would know
the the so the the DWP secretary makes
decisions under statute about things
like Universal Credit there's a process
that the DWP secretary goes through
every Autumn that is happening or that
will be happening shortly in the normal
way so I don't there's nothing I can say
one way or the other about Universal
Credit that's going through its normal
uh process but to answer your point
about the top rate that was about 1 20th
about less than five percent
of the fiscal measures in the growth
plan the growth plan contains broadly
based tax cuts that benefit all Working
Families around about 30 million people
which will see them 450 pounds a year uh
better off on average the the additional
rate uh measure if you look at the table
it was a relatively small very small
part in fact of the total measures it
was less than one twentieth of all of
the measures in the plan taken as a
whole
yeah but you're missing the Optics here
are you not Mr philp the fact is fat
cats getting shed slow shed loads more
money is how my viewers will be seeing
it this morning as opposed to people who
are deciding whether or not they can put
food in their kids bellies do you it's
not about your money and that's why it's
about the Optics yes that's right and
you thought it was a good idea
you thought it was a good idea so we do
accept no you what we do except it was a
good idea
well a number of people thought it was a
good idea
explain you this morning and you thought
it was a good idea yes
so the economics the economics of this
there's a very strong economic case
which I've been setting out on your
program and others in the last week or
so which is to do with economic
competitiveness it's about as you played
the clip from the chancellor in the
House of Commons
um from a couple of weeks ago saying
that we need to be economically
competitive compared to other countries
to make sure people locate here so that
was the economic argument it's quite a
good one however there is another
argument which is the one you've just
made about the Optics and the
juxtaposition of the tax cut for people
on higher incomes at a difficult time
and we the government has accepted the
chancellor and prime minister have
accepted that that argument the case
that you just put is the more important
one and that's why they've changed their
mind uh which is I think the right thing
to do in response to people's very
strong feelings there is an economic
argument on the other side that they've
weighed them up which is the one I just
mentioned briefly a second ago they've
weighed the two up and come to their
decision
um the Prime Minister said yesterday
that it was the Chancellor's um decision
uh not hers
well I mean they you know the chancellor
is the minister who is primarily
responsible obviously for
um budget decisions that's just a
statement of regular fact but of course
you know they talk to each other a great
deal and to other ministers as well and
it's ultimately
um collectively uh decided and supported
okay so she was wrong to say that it was
the Chancellor's decision
she was right to say the chancellor is
the minister primarily responsible for
this policy area but obviously it gets
discussed more widely as well okay it's
great to talk to you I know that you're
going to have a rough run this morning
of talking to other media but we
appreciate you coming to talk to us as
always thank you
okay thank you okay